[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute wieder ein ganz
spontaner das video so zwischendurch
kommen mit dieser spontanen ideen und
dann geschnappt haben wir seine kamera
und wir film drauflos schütze ich meine
schütze und so und du nimmst noch so
kleine kopfhörer und wir machen hier
gerade ein zwetschgenkuchen das filmen
wir richtig ab das ist richtig geplant
gewesen und jetzt haben wir mal so
hunger zwischendurch während der
hefeteig geht und habe ich mir gedacht
flammkuchen das wäre erst jetzt so
richtig leckere knackiger flammkuchen
und super schnell zubereitet
unkompliziert und das zeige ich euch
jetzt schon mal mehl in eine schüssel
und meinsam kuchenteig besteht aus vier
zutaten einmal mehl wasser das gebe ich
hier schon mit dazu dann natürlich etwas
salz und olivenöl kommt dann auch mit
dazu
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich den tag ungefähr drei
minuten lang geknetet und der ist schön
weich also der ist wirklich sehr weich
und auch so ein ticken klebrig wenn man
so möchte also nicht so viel mehr drauf
tun damit er nicht so hart wird jetzt
gebe ich mail auf die arbeitsfläche und
rollen auf backblech größe aus dann gebe
ich auf mein backblech noch
sonnenblumenöl und dann wird einmal
draufgelegt
[Musik]
und diesmal nämlich sonnenblumenöl
olivenöl auf dem heißen blechdach im
heißen ofen kommt nicht so gut olivenöl
darf man nie so stark erhitzen aber
oliven sind es wiederum nicht so schlimm
also nur falls ihr euch das jetzt fragt
und das ist für schwierig ist maschine
mit den sauberen fingern und da gebe ich
jetzt den teig drauf und dann kommt
schon unser topping zum einsatz ist
unser stand
[Musik]
so salz und pfeffer genügt hier
vollkommen beim schmandt werfer könnt
ihr nachher nochmal oben drüber gehen
singen mache ich jetzt hier so ein
bisschen sparsamer und jetzt verstreiche
ich das ganz einfach auf dem teig den
ofen habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt auf
220 grad ober und unterhitze
[Musik]
und jetzt gebe ich da in dünne scheiben
geschnittene rote zwiebeln drauf und da
eigentlich könnte jetzt alles drauf
machen was sie möchte ja traditionell
ist einmal schinken wir persönlich essen
ja kein schinken aber man könnte passte
man nehme das ist türkischer rinder
schinken hatte sogar hassen sich zum
frühstück gegessen hat morgen
ich glaub mal was haben ach komm machen
war machen wir drauf die chose kurz
ruhig
jetzt haben wir hier noch rinder
schinken
er ist halt typisch türkisch und wo ich
gerade von typisch türkisch spreche ihr
könnt natürlich auch sub nehmen aber ich
finde ein bisschen fett ich um ehrlich
zu sein
[Musik]
so meine zuckersüßen da draußen es kommt
jetzt in den vorgeheizten backofen bei
ihm zusammenlaufen
in den vorgeheizten backofen
ich fühle mich wieso diese kita
sendungen oder so laufen und dabei
erzählen 220 grad ober und unterhitze
ich sagen kann ist bei mir gedauert ich
tippe auf zehn bis zwölf minuten
ok ich mich korrigieren 18 minuten hat
es gedauert aber jeder offenbar kann das
also schaut immer mal wieder nachher
darf nicht zu dunkel sein
[Musik]
ich habe mich voller schrecken
ja so ja ich hab ich halt vertan aber
ist er die schlimm genug dass er nicht
zu dunkel wird das ist ganz wichtig und
ich werde jetzt hier noch in grobe
ungleichmäßige stücke schneiden
das ist okay das ist nicht schlimm das
ist ein etabliertes backblech und wann
immer lebt das backblech und da darf man
darauf schneiden an sonst nimmt ihr euch
irgendeine unterlage wohl drauf
schneiden könnt und wir können uns jetzt
soll ich noch sagen wir machen es noch
die fotos können stars und schreibe ich
die ganz genauen mengenangaben unten in
die infobox und dann sehen wir uns im
nächsten video hunger wir ja unseren
guten appetit
guten appetit und falls ihr gerne noch
mehr herzhafte rezepte sehen wollt gerne
eure vorschläge in die kommentare
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten mal nicht vergessen aber nicht
vergessen auch sagt ihr sowieso die
besten also ist dann tschüss
[Musik]